what's up
what's it
you know we'd already be there if Roman
wasn't driving Fort Knox on wheels
you shining baby
we're locked inside it's a trap that's
the bomb all right dorks what are we
blowing up what the Vatican
they're going to hell
oh
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
and never be the man I am today
and now I am the man who's going to
break your family
Peace by peace the devil's coming
oh
dummy I knew you would come for me how
about we all just start shooting each
other time to end this
[Music]
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
cheers we need weapons
and cars
just kidding cars do you like surprises
I adore them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down you lose
your last ride
then you might want to buckle up
foreign